in online chess is equipment and having
the right equipment more important it's
very hard to say exactly how important
it is because we don't have a lot of
data
but it does feel
um
as though
when when i like have a good
um good setup that i i feel better and i
should play better at the start um i
would would play a couple tournaments
just with
um
with my my laptop and like with a webcam
and a very simple setup and
uh i didn't like that as much as like
having
like when you're having you have a good
chair and you have a monitor and
it feels a bit fresher are you a one
monitor kind of guy or two or three even
no i mean you can only have one monitor
when you play but
when i do other things i will
like
having more monetary so that i can
like for instance if i'm watching
football or i'm watching nba it's
good to have several screens how about
the mouse do you have like a pacific no
kind of mouse and brand that you have to
use or
um
i don't have a particular um
[Music]
preference when it comes to
master i'm not that speedy anyway so i'm
not sure i'm not really sure it matters
i thought you were known to be very
speedy aren't you no um i'm like very
good at chess and
just fast enough that i can sort of get
by and bullets
are you practicing it all though like
the mouse skills for example no i
haven't done that in a long time